[Música]
sexta jornada de la Cumbre climática de
la ONU que se desarrolla en Egipto
marcada por la presencia de Estados
Unidos en su intervención el presidente
Joe biden Se comprometió a ayudar en la
transición energética y a reducir las
emisiones de carbono para el año 2030
Tenemos reporte desde charmershake
las tropas de Ucrania retoman el control
de la ciudad de gerson tras La retirada
del ejército ruso sin embargo
Moscú Man tiene que su salida militar no
cambia el estatus de la región
anexionada a Rusia
primer día de la Cumbre de la se han
centrado en la crisis de myanmar los
líderes de la asociación de Naciones del
sudeste asiático acordaron comprometerse
con los grupos de la oposición frente a
la ausencia de aplicación del plan de
paz negociado en abril del año pasado
con la junta militar que tomó El poder
del país
Buenas tardes Bienvenidos a las noticias
de Franz 24 en español Soy Rosa Pérez
mateu y es para mí un gusto acompañarles
empezamos esta edición en Egipto porque
finalmente el presidente de Estados
Unidos Joe biden pronunció su discurso
en la cop 27 luego de que no estuviera
presente en la llamada cumbre de los
líderes el 7 y el 8 de noviembre debido
a la celebración de las elecciones
legislativas de medio término en su país
ante la Cumbre climática vaiden prometió
nuevas metas para reducir los gases de
metano de Estados Unidos pero no hizo
promesas concretas para financiar el
fondo contra los daños y las pérdidas la
mayor exigencia de los países menos
industrializados y menos contaminantes
nuestras enviadas especiales a charmel
Shake María Clara caya y marina Colorado
con los detalles
tres grandes compromisos hizo el
presidente Joe biden aquí en la cop 27
la primera es la creación del plan de
acción sobre el metano con el que se
espera que Estados Unidos reduzca en un
87% sus emisiones de este gas de aquí a
2030 otro de los anuncios es duplicar el
respaldo que da al fondo de adaptación
para llegar a 100 millones el doble de
lo que prometió en la Cup 26 en Glasgow
y otro de los anuncios es dedicar 150
millones para acelerar el plan de fondo
de emergencia para adaptación y
resiliencia y dentro de ellos se cuentan
500 millones para ayudar a Egipto a una
transición energética algo que hace en
Alianza con la Unión Europea y Alemania
el presidente biden no habló sin embargo
de una de las promesas esperadas que era
reducir las emisiones de los
contratistas federales en Estados Unidos
por otra parte
defendió la ley para la reducción de
inflación con la que dedicó 170 mil
millones de dólares para combatir el
cambio climático sin embargo los
activistas estadounidenses dicen que
claramente sí es el plan más grande en
la historia pero porque nunca ha habido
otro y que este monto representa tan
solo el 4% de lo que se destina al
presupuesto de defensa también el
problema principal de la ley para la
reducción de inflación es que no hace
nada para enfrentar nuestros problemas
de combustibles fósiles en el mundo solo
destina dinero para la energía renovable
pero también afianza el interés por los
combustibles fósiles le da a las
compañías de combustibles fósiles las
posibilidades para ser más nuevos
arrendamientos para explorar gas y
petróleo y Esa es la dirección opuesta
de donde Necesitamos ir
lo que le pedimos a Estados Unidos es
que cree una especie de mecanismo de
financiación que pueda hacerle frente a
los daños y las pérdidas y comienza a
financiar las clases de reparación que
son necesarias por parte de los grandes
contaminadores de Estados Unidos y que
han afectado a las comunidades que poco
hicieron para causar el problema
y en el marco de la cop 27 Franz 24 les
ofrece una serie de reportajes relativos
a la crisis climática en Ecuador el
retroceso del 50% de los glaciares
volcánicos es una de las consecuencias
más evidentes del calentamiento global
el informes de nuestro corresponsal
Gustavo Ortega Luisa Machado el parque
nacional anti Sara su tarea de proteger
el volcán es cada vez más ardua el
deshielo avanza cada año y atenta con
dejar sin agua a la población que habita
en la capital ecuatoriana el retroceso
es de 20 a 25 metros por año y eso es
realmente preocupante es una cantidad de
retroceso muy muy pronunciada que que a
la vez afecta tanto a la producción de
agua Además del deshielo el agua que se
consume en la capital ecuatoriana
proviene de esta laguna de origen
glaciar a 35 kilómetros del volcán
antisana la crisis climática y la
escasez de lluvias amenazan estos
reservorios naturales
haciendo sus niveles de agua
la sequía también preocupa Patricio
Muñoz guardaparques quien conoce el
lugar desde hace 40 años para proteger
la diversidad vegetal siembra huertos
que aspira convertir en 5000 nuevas
plantas al año la vegetación puede
constantemente por la falta de lluvias y
el incremento del sol se contabilizaban
hasta
300 días de lluvia no y apenas teníamos
un mes
entre medio seco o medio húmedo hoy
totalmente ha cambiado
me agrada que la zona de amortiguamiento
aún la tenemos además de la flora
también la fauna está sufriendo de los
estragos de los cambios de temperatura
ante la migración de muchas especies
Luisa vigila que el cóndor ave típica
nacional en peligro de extinción
permanezca en su hábitat natural
camino al antisana el desgaste glaciar
devela sus capas rocosas a kilómetros de
distancia y confirma nuevas amenazas las
microplásticos Y eso también es un
factor que durante años ya sea por
actividades turísticas por actividades
antrópicas y el mismo ambiente ya tiene
microplásticos y están depositándose en
el Nevado En total son 120.000 hectáreas
diarias protegidas amenazadas de
desaparecer este parque natural
poblaciones enteras quedarían sin agua y
ya no existiría el ecosistema más rico
de Ecuador
en noticias relativas a la Guerra de
Ucrania el ejército ucraniano retomó el
control de la ciudad de gerson tras La
retirada total de las tropas rusas de la
urbe recordemos que jerson era la mayor
ciudad bajo control de Moscú y un punto
geoestratégico en la Guerra sin embargo
Rusia mantiene que la salida militar de
la ciudad no cambia su estatuto de zona
anexionada según el kremlin tras su
retirada de jerson No quedan tropas
rusas al oeste del Río niéper el sistema
fluvial que divide Ucrania por la mitad
Juan Pablo lucumí tiene los detalles
[Aplausos]
[Música]
recibidos como Héroes los soldados
ucranianos entraron en la Plaza de la
libertad de gerson en medio de aplausos
de quienes celebran La retirada del
ejército ruso de la única capital
regional que Moscú había tomado desde el
inicio de la guerra
este viernes Rusia aseguró haber
concluido de forma total su retirada y
Ucrania celebra la retoma del control de
una ciudad estratégica la ciudad de
gerson se encuentra en su etapa final
hay mucho trabajo para limpiar el área
de minar la ciudad tenemos entendido que
los ocupantes antes de irse hicieron
estallar la planta de energía térmica de
gerson estación de distribución de la
compañía de energía de la región junto a
la torre de televisión destruyeron parte
electrónica de la misma Tendremos que
restaurarlo todo para el kremlin el
repliegue no cambia el estatus quo
asegurando que no hubo bajas en sus
tropas y que no dejaron atrás ni una
sola pieza de armamento gerson es un
tema de la federación rusa está
legalmente fijado y definido no hay
cambios y no puede haber cambios sin
embargo según las autoridades ucranianas
varios soldados rusos terminaron
ahogados tratando de salir de la urbe y
varios de Ellos están en posiciones
fortificadas que construyeron
recientemente del otro lado del río
nieper los medios ucranianos informaron
que el único punto de paso entre la
ciudad de gerson y la otra orilla del
río nieper el había colapsado el cruce
más cercano a 70 kilómetros y aledaño a
novakhofka también está en medio de
tensiones Pues de ambas partes se acusan
de atacar una Represa clave que de
romperse generaría un caudal que
arrasaría con poblaciones enteras e
inundaría a
y precisamente desde la invasión rusa de
Ucrania el suministro de combustible a
Europa por parte de Rusia disminuyó un
80%. Alemania la mayor economía de
Europa y altamente dependiente del
garruso prevé largos apagones por lo que
sus ciudadanos se preparan para
enfrentar una situación inédita para
muchos Rafael Pérez nos cuenta más
lo que alguna vez solo vieron en la
ficción hoy es una amenaza real a la que
deben acostumbrarse quedarse a oscuras
están recurriendo a cursos de
capacitación para saber cómo actuar en
caso deberse en un apagón
si se va la electricidad Entonces ya
nada funcionará y Debemos entender Qué
significa realmente nada funciona eso va
desde Llamar a los servicios de
emergencia hasta ver las luces de la
calle apagadas y eso representa estar a
oscuras como la boca de un lobo en la
calle y luego en las casas también está
completamente oscuro y nada funciona los
cursos se ofrecen de manera gratuita por
la organización alemana de ayuda y
bienestar amparados por la agencia
gubernamental de protección civil y
asistencia en Casos de desastre la
crisis energética mundial impulsada por
la invasión rusa Ucrania y las sanciones
impuestas por la Unión Europea Moscú
complican el abastecimiento de
combustible al viejo continente
hace tres generaciones la gente sabía lo
que era estar sin electricidad hoy nos
damos cuenta de que apenas podemos
funcionar sin electricidad así que
puedes verlo rápido que se desarrollan y
cambian las cosas y sin electricidad las
cosas cambian prácticamente se paralizan
no moriremos por eso pero la vida diaria
se paraliza
con las reservas de combustibles casi
llenas Alemania espera evitar los
apagones gracias a una inusual calidez
imperante lo que contribuye al ahorro
en otras noticias El Vaticano acaba de
anunciar que abrirá una investigación
contra el cardenal francés Jean Pierre
ricard quien esta semana reconoció que
abusó sexualmente de una menor de 14
años hace décadas El Vaticano informó
que la investigación formal empezará
cuando haya concluido el trabajo de la
justicia francesa para que las
conclusiones de las autoridades de
Francia puedan servir de base a las
pesquisas del Vaticano el Papa Francisco
podría condenar al cardenal francés a
una vida de aislamiento y penitencia o
bien apartarlo del sacerdocio recordemos
que el año pasado una investigación
independiente reveló que hombres
relacionados con el clero católico
francés abusaron de 200.000 menores en
los últimos 70 años
y en otras noticias en el primer día de
cumbre de la asean la asociación de
Naciones del sudeste asiático los
líderes acordaron comprometerse con los
grupos de la oposición de miar frente a
la ausencia de aplicación del plan de
paz negociado en abril del año pasado
con la junta militar mi armar sigue
formando parte de lacean a pesar de los
llamados de grupos de Defensores de
Derechos Humanos para que sea expulsado
leorel tiene los detalles
Un año más La silla de nyanmar estuvo
vacía en la apertura de la Cumbre del
asean los líderes militares Siguen sin
poder asistir a las reuniones
importantes de la organización y se
arriesgan a ser excluidos
definitivamente si no empiezan a aplicar
el plan de paz acordado en abril de 2021
dentro del bloque Indonesia ha sido una
de las principales voces pidiendo una
acción más dura contra la junta de
myanmar
Indonesia está profundamente
decepcionada la situación en mi armar
está empeorando no hay avances
significativos en la implementación del
consenso de los cinco puntos y luego no
hay compromiso de la junta no debemos
permitir que la situación en mi amar
defina a la Asia
mi hermana ha entrado en una espiral de
conflicto sangrientos desde que los
militares de aerocaron el gobierno de
anson suquía en febrero de 2021 el
secretario general de Naciones Unidas
Antonio Gutiérrez condenó de nuevo la
escalada de violencia y la crisis en
materia de Derechos Humanos que vive el
país
los ataques indiscriminados contra la
población civil pueden constituir
crímenes de guerra según el derecho
internacional reitero mi llamamiento a
las autoridades demián para que liberen
a todos los presos políticos y pongan en
marcha inmediatamente un proceso para
volver a la transición democrática Este
es el único camino hacia la paz
las potencias occidentales han impuestos
sanciones a la junta mientras la
violencia se ha intensificado en las
últimas semanas con mortíferos ataques
militares aéreos contra objetivos
civiles
gracias por su atención sigan con
nosotros
[Música]